wer hat in diesem Jahr zu Hause noch
warm und wer nicht das wird zu großen
Gerechtigkeitsfrage in Deutschland wer
kann sich die warme Heizung nicht mehr
leisten und wer bekommt die warme
Wohnung vom Staat vom Steuerzahler
bezahlt die große Diskussion sie läuft
in Deutschland bildchefredakteur und
tv-chef Klaus Strunz schreibt das er
schreibt das gefährdet den sozialen
Frieden wenn nämlich Rentner frieren und
familienpleite gehen während illegale
Einwanderer warme Unterkünfte haben
Einwanderer und Hartz IV Empfänger bei
ihnen übernimmt der Staat ja die
Heizkosten alle anderen Zahlen selbst
wie ist Ihre Meinung dazu finden Sie das
gerecht ich finde schon ungerecht dass
die Hartz-IV-Empfänger das so ohne
weiteres gezahlt bekommen man müsste
entweder immer so gasdeckel halt eben
machen das ist auch so ein Grundbedarf
ist einfach für alle gleich und das in
England gemacht ist aber nicht so
punktuell ist einstreuen von
irgendwelchen Werten halt eben wo man
meint die sind jetzt besonders bedürftig
die sind jetzt weniger das ist
staatswirtschaften das geht komplett die
falsche Richtung aus meiner Sicht dass
die Hartz IV genau oder Flüchtlinge
aufdrehen können wir müssen sparen wo es
da die Gerechtigkeit dann also das ist
ja die große Frage generell unser Gehalt
wird ja sonst aufgebraucht für Strom Gas
so dass sich der normale sozusagen
nichts mehr zu essen kaufen kann das ist
auf dem Punkt gebracht und dann bricht
ja auch die ganze Wirtschaft dann
zusammen ich finde es bisschen ungerecht
dass wir für unser Geld arbeiten und
dann so hohe Preise zahlen müssen und
das ist sehr kritisch wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe gibt es nur
offizielle Energieverordnung wo gesagt
wird dass alle offiziellen Gebäude auf
19 Grad runtergekühlt werden müssen und
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass man das
auch für Flüchtlingsheime und andere
offizielle Unterkünfte dann darauf
überträgt eben vom Staat auch finanziert
werden das glaube ich nicht dass da 25
Grad herrschen können das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen wir haben unser Leben
lang für unsere Renten gearbeitet
genauso meine Tochter mein Schwiegersohn
arbeiten nach wie vor Zahlen schön ihre
erklären gehen aber immer leer aus und
das finde ich ungerecht
Deutschland ist ein Sozialstaat ist auch
absolut in Ordnung ich bin nicht dafür
dass man jemanden hungern oder frieren
lässt aber unser deutsches System
überhaupt Hartz IV
ich finde da könnte man etwas
zurückhaltender sein das sagen sie dass
es ihre Meinung die große
Gerechtigkeitsfrage wer hat es noch warm
zu Hause in diesem Herbst und Winter die
einen die sich die hohen Heizkosten
trotz Arbeit nicht mehr leisten können
und die anderen die das vom Staat vom
Steuerzahler bezahlt bekommen das sind
dazu die Hintergründe
wie gerecht ist Deutschland in der
Gaskrise Stichwort Familien sie leiden
besonders unter den hohen Abschlägen die
Feldmanns aus Niedersachsen haben 2.400
Euro netto im Monat davon bezahlt die
dreiköpfige Familie ihr Haus und die
extrem hohen Kosten für Strom Wasser und
Gas macht
1.154 € von denen die Familie noch Auto
Sprit und Lebensmittel bezahlen muss da
bleibt kaum was übrig
Stichwort Rentner Dietmar m aus Zwickau
bringt der hohe gasabschlag sogar in die
Existenznot genau ab dem 23
November 22 verlangt die Firma MITGAS
monatlich von mir einen Betrag in Höhe
von
2268 Euro und ich bin nicht in der Lage
diese Summe monatlich zu zahlen das sind
bei 11 Abschlägen knapp 25.000 €. so
viel wie ein Auto statt bislang
eigentlich 165 Euro muss der Rentner ab
November unglaubliche
2268 Euro pro Monat zahlen eine Erhöhung
von über
1.370%. und Hartz IV Empfänger und
Flüchtlinge für sie bezahlt der Staat
die Heizkosten wie gerecht ist das
Gegenüber Rentnern und Familien die
alles selbst zahlen müssen das
Entlastungspaket der Ampel ist nur ein
Tropfen auf den heißen Stein
Rentner bekommen einmalig 300 Euro
Studenten 200 Euro und das Kindergeld
wird nur um 18 Euro pro Monat erhöht
also wie gerecht geht es zu in
Deutschland im teuer Winter
und es dauert ja auch noch bis das Geld
dann wirklich da ist die große
Gerechtigkeitsfrage auch deshalb wer hat
es noch warm zu Hause in diesem Herbst
und Winter und wer eben nicht wer
diskutieren darüber heute weiter ganz
offen ganz ehrlich bei Bild live gleich
auch mit Klaus Strutz hier und jetzt mit
Michael Schäfer er ist
energiefachberater aus Merzenich und ein
Mann den wir aus dem Ahrtal kennen dort
kennengelernt haben wo er mit seinen
Händen angepackt hat in der großen
Flutkatastrophe schönen guten Tag Herr
Schäfer
ja wir haben gerade darüber berichtet
den einen wird die Heizung komplett
bezahlt und das ist so viele Jahre auch
völlig in Ordnung natürlich gewesen die
anderen wissen aber in dieser Zeit nicht
wie sie über die Runden kommen sollen
die Steuerzahler ist es ungerecht
ich glaube persönlich man sollte das
nicht gegeneinander ausspielen das ist
einfach eine glaube ich auch eine Art
und Weise mittlerweile
die relativ ungerecht sind wenn wir mal
sehen tatsächlich wie viel Menschen
Hartz IV Empfänger sind jetzt nicht nur
die die man immer sieht wo man immer
meint die mit den T-Shirts rumlaufen äh
keine Lust auf Arbeit das sind nicht die
Leute wir haben heute viele Berufstätige
die zusätzlich Hartz IV bekommen weil
die Löhne nicht mehr reichen auch ich in
meinem Job aber tagtäglich mit den
Menschen zu tun und kann Ihnen sagen es
ist wieder Rentner vorher das schon mal
gesagt hat es ist immens was da gerade
in Deutschland passiert die
Heizkosten steigen so enorm die Leute
viele Leute die angepasst wurden jetzt
anstatt 150er 200 € auf einmal
800 900.000 1.200 bei mir wird ab Januar
ungefähr 1400 Euro im Monat sein
und man sollte die Menschen nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen wir sind
Sozialstaat und da muss den Ärmsten der
Armen geholfen werden dazu zählen auch
mittlerweile sehr sehr viel Rentner ganz
genau nur der Blick deswegen die
Diskussion richtet sich jetzt eben auch
immer mehr auf die die Arbeiten die eben
Geld verdienen die Steuern zahlen und
trotzdem im Grunde nicht zum Leben haben
trotzdem ihre Energierechnung nicht
zahlen können wie viele von diesen
Menschen kennen sie
also ich bin ja Fachberater
energiefachberater auch im Bereich
Photovoltaik aber also jeden Tag ca 3
Kundenbesuche wo ich bei den Kunden bin
die halt eben irgendwo mit der
Photovoltaik versuchen wollen zu sparen
das Problem ist dass die ganze
Gesetzgebung so verkehrt ist weil der
Rentner der in seiner Wohnung sitzt kann
sich gegen die Strom- und gaskonzepte
einfach nicht wehren weil er kann sich
nicht einfach auf sein Dach oben
Photovoltaikanlage drauflegen oder kann
seine Heizung verändern das ist das
große Problem was wir haben und ich habe
es also wirklich so das fast alle die
über eine Photovoltaikanlage nachdenken
gleichzeitig natürlich auch schon im
vorursten und sagen okay Gas kann ich
nicht mehr bezahlen wir reden hier
wieder bei dem Rentner den sie da gerade
vorher drin hatten von einem Menschen
der über 2000 Euro für Gas bezahlen muss
das ist ja noch nicht alles dazu kommt
ja auch noch mal der Strompreis der sich
mittlerweile verdoppelt hat bloß der
Staat reagiert ja nicht drauf es wird
über den Deckel gesprochen
dann weiß man auch schon man redet auch
schon darüber dass man darüber nachdenkt
wofür dürfen nicht nachdenken ja auch
der Scholz der sagt ja dann sollen doch
die Arbeitgeber 3000 Euro zahlen da
fragen Sie mal einen kleinen Bäcker der
jetzt anstatt 1500 Euro im Monat 15 oder
20.000 im Monat Strom bezahlt und er
soll seinen Mitarbeitern jetzt auch noch
3000 Euro geben die dann nicht
versteuert werden ich kann die ganzen
Ideen die diese Politik hat überhaupt
gar nicht mehr nachvollziehen die sind
so weit weg von den Menschen die haben
sich soweit entfernt die Politiker das
ist einfach nur traurig ist
was sagen Ihnen diejenigen zu denen sie
jetzt gerade kommen als
energiefachberater was steht bei denen
auf der Abschlagszahlung und wie viel
Wut hat sich da angestaut
also ich habe es jetzt auch tatsächlich
ein kleines Beispiel eine junge Familie
mit zwei Kindern die mussten uns ihm ja
hatten relativ günstiges Haus zur Miete
mussten da im letzten Jahr rauslegen
wegen der Flut auch zum Teil weil der
Sohn des Vermieters war hat abgesoffen
mit seinem Haus und dann haben die das
auf eigene Bedarf gekündigt damals so
der hat jetzt eine Wohnung hier bei uns
mitten in Düren sehr teuer weil auch
kaum Wohnungen zu bekommen waren für
1000 €. so der junge Mann geht arbeiten
verdient 2500 Euro der hat jetzt eine
Ankündigung bekommen er muss jetzt
anstatt 150 € Gas 800 zahlen und anstatt
120 Euro Strom 300 € Strom damit ist
sein Gehalt weg
mit Miete und den Eltern bleiben in nur
300 Euro zum Leben mit einer
vierköpfigen Familie der hat ein Auto wo
wieder zur Arbeit fahren muss ja aber
auch hier da schlecht rauskommt und
schlechthin kommt
erklären sie so eine Menschen mal der
sitzt vorhin verzweifelt und sagt was
soll ich denn machen ich kann nichts
machen auch wenn man immer wieder hört
Einsparung es ist doch so wir sind auch
in Deutschland so weit es geht doch
keiner hin und baut sich nur 100 Watt
Birne rein in seine Lampe alle Leute
sparen doch schon ich habe auch diesen
kleinen
Wassersparer in meinem Duschkopf den
habe ich schon seit Jahren da drin ich
habe alles auf
LED umgebaut wir sparen da wo wir können
aber der Staat macht jetzt etwas diese
Strompreis und Gasexplosion die ihr
gerade stattfindet
ist meiner Meinung ein Verbrechen am
Volk und das kann man mittlerweile nicht
mehr anders sagen die Bevölkerung blutet
aus wir haben 50 60 Prozent der
Bevölkerung die diese Kosten nicht mehr
tragen können und das ist die arbeitende
Bevölkerung genauso wie der Hartz IV
Empfänger
ein Wort noch Herr Chef hat zu den
Menschen der Ahrtal wir haben während
sie gesprochen haben auch immer wieder
Bilder von dort gezeigt wo sie angepackt
haben wo sie ehrenamtlich geholfen haben
über so lange Zeit jetzt liegt diese
Flutkatastrophe mittlerweile relativ
lange zurück aber ja nicht für die
Menschen die dort leben für die ist das
alles noch ganz frisch die sind noch
nicht viel weiter eigentlich als kurz
nach der Flutkatastrophe die haben den
ersten Winter erlebt größtenteils noch
ohne Heizung im kalten jetzt kommt der
zweite Winter in denen sie ja ihre
Heizung nicht bezahlen müssen wie geht
es den Menschen dort im Ahrtal
also immer noch sehr schlecht ich bin
auch selber mit als beruflich jetzt auch
das ab und an mal im Aartal gewesen
sind immer noch ca 70 Prozent der
Menschen die keine Heizung haben
was natürlich Prozent 70 Prozent sagen
70 Prozent dann immer noch keine Heizung
im Aartal
und wenn dann ich habe es jetzt mit
einem Flut
Opfer gehabt bei dem war ich jetzt da
der hat sich relativ günstig irgendwo
eine Gasheizung geholt und jetzt hauen
sie ihm die Gaspreise um die Ohren der
sagt auch also es kann doch nicht sein
was passiert denn hier eigentlich jetzt
haben wir glücklicherweise in einer
derer die eine Heizung hat und jetzt
kriege ich Gaspreise die ich nicht mehr
bezahlen kann
ja das ist man kann das gar nicht
nachvollziehen die Leute aus dem Aartal
wurden ja nun permanenten kann man es
auch nicht anders sagen in den Hintern
getreten warum erst war die Fluter was
wäre ohne die ganzen privaten Helfer und
ich habe sehr viele davon kennengelernt
tolle Menschen wenn die nicht da gewesen
wären
als hätte der Staat hätte da schon der
hat auch da schon versagt und hätte noch
mehr versagt mir hat die Flut
tatsächlich eins wiedergegeben den
glauben an unsere Bevölkerung weil die
funktioniert egal ob es in der Flut ist
oder ihr Ukraine Krieg wo man sieht wie
viel Menschen helfen aber man bekommt
irgendwann auch das Gefühl dass der
Staat ein ausnutzt
und das finde ich schlimm und deshalb
bin ich auch der Meinung man sollte
langsam doch tatsächlich mal auf die
Straße gehen um einfach dem Staat auch
mal zeigen so geht das nicht weiter das
sollte man alles friedlich tun ja
aber man muss dem Staat irgendwann auch
mal zeigen es ist irgendwo ein Punkt
gekommen wo man Schluss machen muss und
der Punkt ist jetzt erreicht weil 50 bis
60% der Menschen sind von diesen
wahnsinnigen
Preiskalkulation betroffen sie haben den
Mund aufgemacht heute früh bei Bild live
ich danke Ihnen herzlich herr Schäfer
Energieberater der solange ehrenamtlich
im Ahrtal geholfen hat und der jetzt
sagt wie die Energiepreise durch die
Decke knallen wie wenig Menschen sich
das noch leisten können und das immer
noch 70% der Menschen im Aartal so sagte
er ohne Heizung sind in diesem Winter
ohnehin frieren danke für Ihre wichtigen
Worte heute bei Bild live die wird heute
jeder in Deutschland sehen danke Herr
Schäfer
[Musik]